inflation has one cause and one cause
only
protesters on The View I like to be as
surprised as you all are when I come
back to work things went off the rails
during a live interview with Ted Cruz
Monday when protesters in the audience
interrupted the Senator's remarks with
loud chants about climate change
we have seen trillions and trillions of
dollars spent by Joe Biden the Democrats
just last year last year the federal
government took in four trillion dollars
in tax revenues most money in history
we've ever taken in yeah and Whoopi she
wasn't standing for it ladies ladies
excuse us let us do our job let us do
our job we're here with you have to say
but you gotta go
you gotta go you gotta let us do our job
I just leave I go home and go home to my
life and I take care of my cat and do
all the stuff I'm supposed to do
following a commercial break Whoopi's
co-host Anna Navarro issued an apology
listen I've been very vocal and very
critical of you but I'm sorry that this
has happened uh not good in our house a
spokesperson for the view issued a
statement to ET about the incident
explaining quote three members of the
audience interrupted The View today
during Senator Ted Cruz's appearance
protesting about climate they were
promptly escorted out by security
despite the drama it seems there's no
hard feelings on Ted's end he posted a
clip from his appearance on the show to
his Instagram and this behind the scenes
shot telling fans to tune in
Whoopi who's been a host on The View for
15 years knows a thing or two about
being in the hot seat because it's not
about winning over people it's about
telling as much of the truth as we have
when E.T caught up with the actress
ahead of season 26 she shared how she
deals with critical viewers who've got
strong opinions I mean we can have as
much fun with a subject like that as we
can but at the same time reminding
people that you know
great things are happening not
everything everybody wants at the same
time is happening and we're all
benefiting you know we're all benefiting
the key is to get people in who actually
wouldn't benefit the country if we can
do that you know we can still have
arguments and fights because nobody's
going to do it the way that everybody
wants it done but we'll have better
standing ground because it's not about
your race it's not about your gender
it's it's about what's best for the
country
foreign